merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jean pierre vigier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture monsieur le ministre
nos agriculteurs vous rendent ce que
vous leur faites vous leur tourner le
dos et ils vous tourne le dos nos
agriculteurs peuvent avoir le dos large
homme de la terre ils savent en durée
mais désormais vous devez agir
nos agriculteurs attendent des actions
concrètes et pas seulement des
négociations à bruxelles
certes nécessaire mais toutefois
insuffisante la commission européenne
vous donne un feu vert pour agir alors
allez-vous mettre le pied sur
l'accélérateur
ce passage à la vitesse supérieure vous
le devez à nos agriculteurs ainsi qu'à
notre ruralité 80% de notre territoire
français notre france rurale ne veut pas
voir ses exploitations agricoles
disparaître les unes après les autres
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence à
prendre des mesures qui répondent aux
problèmes de fond d'une crise agricole
qui s'enlise
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence à
arrêter votre politique anti entreprise
menée depuis quatre ans et donc pas 10
évoquent les allez allez
monsieur le ministre et la fin de la
question à ce que nos paysans vivent
décemment du fruit de leur travail
alors quand allez vous considérez notre
agriculture comme une richesse et une
force pour notre pays
à quand des mesures concrètes et
structurelles pour notre agriculture
française
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean pierre vigier ni d'abord je pense
que vous êtes sucre et stéphane le foll
qui est en ce moment au sénat et donc je
vous prie d'excuser son absence
monsieur le député j'ai entendu dans vos
proco beaucoup d'interpellation des mots
d'ordre très généraux qui prennent en
compte c'est vrai aujourd'hui les
difficultés de nos agriculteurs qui
d'une façon à mon avis injuste et
inopportune mettait en cause le ministre
de l'agriculture qui se mobilisent
depuis des mois et des mois pour notre
agriculture et qui a obtenu
vous avez été obligé de le concéder des
résultats à bruxelles et qui secteur
agricole après secteur agricole qu'il
s'agisse de l'élevage qu'il s'agisse du
port il ya quelques mois s'agissant du
poulet il s'était à chaque fois mobilisé
pour obtenir sur l'ensemble de la
profession des résultats et monsieur le
député je ne crois pas aujourd'hui que
les agriculteurs qui nous vous aurons
écouter puisse se satisfaire des
généralités et de vos capacité
d'indignation qui ne sont pas à la
mesure des propositions que vous seriez
capable d'avancer alors maintenant je
pense qu'il est temps ci voulait
véritablement aider nos agriculteurs que
vous me fassiez un certain nombre de
propositions et que vous ne restez pas
dans la posture
merci monsieur le guen